Let me get this straight. We have our genome, which
contains our genes, that are transcribed and translated into proteins.
>> Right.
>> But, we cut out entire sections, which are introns.
And, we only translate between the start and stop codons?
>> That's exactly right. And on top
of that, there's more DNA sequence called the
promoter region. That doesn't code for any
protein and just controls the initiation of transcription.
>> Okay, but how much of the genome actually turns into
proteins in the end?
>> That's a really good question. Why don't you
take a crack at it. Even if you don't know
the answer, just pick from one of the following. How
much of the genome do you think codes for protein?